bonjour c'est bien bonjour l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
lance donc son calendrier de l'avent
électronique une centaine de cadeaux à
gagner comment faut-il s'y prendre pour
gagner un lot justement c'est assez
simple ce jeu se joue en ligne sur le
site internet ou sur la page facebook de
l'île de loisirs il a commencé ce mardi
1er décembre et se finira le 25 décembre
chaque jour en fait une question est
posée où la réponse se trouve évidemment
quand notre site internet
et chaque jour il ya un tirage au sort
avec entrain les quinze gagnants pour
pouvoir gagner des places pour
participer aux activités sur ville de
loisirs alors les participants
remplissent un formulaire avec leurs
coordonnées et les gagnants seront
informés par mail et recevront leurs
bons cadeaux et directement chez eux
et qu'est-ce qu'on peut gagner alors on
peut gagner beaucoup de choses on peut
gagner des places pour le mini golf des
places pour l'équitation pour les jeux
d'eau des promenades en trottinette des
tickets pour l'accrobranche ou encore
des goodies le maintenir le lien avec
toutes ces personnes qui sont habitués à
fréquenter livre de loisirs et pouvoir
leur donner l'opportunité de pouvoir
revenir dès que ce sera ouvert en
bénéficiant de places gratuites sur les
activités toutes les animations
participe un peu l'événement tous sont
partenaires oui il y en a beaucoup comme
le golf blue green sky équitation ou
encore très peu ingrate
cette jeune entreprise qui a ouvert en
2020 offre durant ce mois de décembre de
l'eau une place achetée une place
offerte choqué aussi voilà une manière
d'accompagner le mouvement et permettre
à des gens qui eux si éventuellement
effectivement n'ont pas forcément même
pouvoir d'achat ou qui sont encore dans
une situation un peu de méfiance
vis-à-vis de l'extérieur de de les
accompagner dans une reprise de
l'activité
sotchi chrono effectivement une manière
d'avoir aussi de la visibilité bien sûr
alors le jeu du calendrier de l'avent a
plutôt du succès puisque cent une
personnes ont déjà participé hier alors
les cinq gagnants
ont pu remporter une heure de location
de paddle pour une personne il vous
reste encore tout le mois de décembre
pour participer jusqu'au 25 forcément
merci célia